all right i have an important message to
all you elected swamp creatures in
washington d.c your willing accomplices
your press secretaries and the media mob
uh you know it is frankly repulsive
just repulsive that all of you biden's
sycophants you sit idly by you say
nothing you do nothing as joe biden
completely mismanages covert 19. you're
supposed to be public servants right
you're elected to be a public servant
serve your constituents who now two
years into the pandemic over the
christmas holiday most americans can't
find a cover test or get one or they
have to wait for hours
that is inexcusable
you're putting petty partisan politics
over the right of any american at this
late date to have access to testing on
demand you know what that makes you
you're all enablers of failure would you
give donald trump a pass like that never
the american people don't even have the
therapeutics and monoclonal antibodies
we've had them for 18 months
americans desperately need them and
guess what we could bring it to them we
just use operation warp speed make all
the tests we need operation warp speed
for monoclonal antibodies operation warp
speed we can do that for the anti-viral
drugs that are now being released we
have fully vaccinated americans those
with fully vaccinated and boosters those
with natural immunity are now testing
positive in the millions we've had any
monoclonal antibodies for 18 months and
again you won't speak up because joe is
a democrat
just like you protected him you let him
stay in the in the candidate protection
program in 2020 you let him be in the
presidential protection program now and
that makes all of you repulsive it is
beyond inexcusable when do you stand up
for the american people you know what
did joe say he said i'm going to shut
down the virus there's no federal
solution you need a test just go out and
google it how about for once you stand
up for the american people and what is
right and that would be testing on
demand
therapeutics on demand antivirals on
demand not that complicated
that's all the time we have left this
evening please set your dvr never miss
an episode hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else